measles now a public health emergency
with a surge of those infected measles
is back in the US the threat so severe
some hospitals arming each entrance with
security guards to screen visitors for
symptoms of the virus in the first few
months of 2019 US doctors reported 314
cases of measles to the Centers for
Disease Control now compare that to the
number of reported cases in the year
2000
less than a hundred what happened
scientists put much of the blame on the
anti-vaccine movement which is thriving
in some parts of the country Washington
State has been called a hot spot because
of its anti-vaccine movement Washington
State where more than 70 cases were
reported is one of 17 states that allows
parents to object to vaccinating their
children on the basis of personal or
moral beliefs and with fewer kids
vaccinated measles is far more likely to
spread
in fact the disease is so contagious
that 93 to 95 percent of a population
must be vaccinated to prevent
transmission yet in a number of states
more parents are seeking non-medical
exemptions from routine immunizations
but here's the thing
overall the u.s. is doing pretty well
when it comes to immunizations if there
is a big vaccine problem it's not here
in the US but abroad in Africa and parts
of Asia and in the Middle East there
were about 20 million infants in 2017
that didn't receive routine
immunizations such as for diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis or DTP and about
60% of them live in ten countries in
Nigeria for example only a third of the
population received the third dose of
DTP in 2017 while that rate is closer to
85% for the rest of the world you see
immunization rates are tied not just to
the lease but to economics poor
countries often lack infrastructure like
electricity which is needed to keep
vaccines refrigerated
consider South Sudan less than 10% of
the population had access to electricity
in 2016 which might help explain why the
country has one of the lowest
immunization rates in the world but
there are also other factors at play
like conflict
following the civil war in Syria for
example immunization rates for some
diseases fell by nearly 40 percent and
that trend is mirrored by other
countries that are also marred with
political strife yes these numbers look
bleak but they are improving thanks to
an increase in awareness and funding for
immunization efforts especially in
countries like Afghanistan Bangladesh
and Sudan and in 2017 a record 123
million children are immunized with at
least one dose of DTP so even as this
anti-vaxxer movement grips parts of the
US as a global species humans are
actually closer than ever to ridding the
world of vaccine preventable deaths